well now I'd like to show you a video
that I saw on Twitter that somebody
spliced together of Disney the Disney
corporation that that Rhonda said this
guy was smacking around not too long ago
then verse now and I think you'll sort
of capture how we lose control of our
own culture over time take a look
for us as a group of people they
slavery which means slaves built this
country the flag means everything to me
it means life it means freedom it also
means unity and it means love we the
descendants of slaves in America have
earned reparations for their suffering
and continue to earn reparations every
moment we spend submerged in the
systemic Prejudice racism and white
supremacy all the flags you know you
ride down the street and it makes you
feel connected like we're in this
together
foreign
[Music]
so now do you see what we're all railing
against uh Connor just made a just made
a great point which is the clips of that
several of those clips are from the show
Proud Family which tells you so the new
ones and the old ones so in the old days
Proud Family same show so you see how we
lose control of these things and they
aim it at children because they're going
for the generations whose minds are
malleable who they can basically turn
them into walking zombies of woke lunacy
[Music]
oh